hey buzzfeed i'm mallory and i'm whitney
and we're starring in the movie stop and
go today we're going to be playing the
game would you rather road trip edition
get ready
[Music]
okay
i'm going to pick whale sound i think so
i'm gonna pick whale sounds because i
think that you might have like a full-on
like
meditative yeah i think it's a thing
yeah i think that genuinely you would
start maybe see in the future but also i
prefer any sound to know sound what i
prefer no silence here look i'll play
something
what is this
there's whale sounds i thought it'd be
soothing
[Music]
i would pay the 11 no i wouldn't i'm
fine stopping every 30 minutes my butt
needs a rest anyway i'm especially like
as an adult what's what's the problem
with just a little bit of leisure as far
as like i don't have to take this at an
aggressive pace it's like it's okay to
run walk if i have to stop at a nasty
gas station and pee every 30 minutes
it's not worth the stop okay just reeks
of truck gasoline and i have a hot take
i don't get grossed out by public
bathrooms it's a gas station it's just
another part of the world that i got to
see we should make some ground rules to
be safe we leave the car as little as
possible i peed on myself the only stop
for gas i'm just trying not to think
about how many people touch that pump
also don't think about that guy over
there
[Music]
if you don't have any money with you at
all then i probably wouldn't have my
phone with me because that's where i
keep my money so i would have to use
my feminine wires yeah that was my
thought too my first and most disturbing
thought which is like the only thing i
could do in both situations
is try to flag someone down with like it
but i know i'm gonna be just like you
know in my driving outfit which is like
your stretchy pants super stretchy no
bra
absolutely no form covered
covered in melted chocolate
i don't know if anyone would stop
[Music]
i was gonna say mice but then i
remembered what it was like to film
here's the thing about the mice too is
that if you
push on those brakes
i have gone on a road trip with my dog
lovely dogs are a gift so i would pick
dogs
[Applause]
i would rather hold the ox for sure
because if i'm driving i'm stuck driving
which means i have to be awake
then i would rather die than have
somebody make me listen to something
that i don't want to like it should be
in my full control if i were driving
with you i would i would rather you hold
the office too that's sweet you would
choose better music and i would be
grateful that you wouldn't fall asleep
at the wheel oh yeah that was
i was
a very very overworked senior in high
school
it's an overachiever
[Music]
toilet paper is a tampon because i've
done it i know that you do it all the
time i don't do it all the time i do it
every once in a while when i don't have
a tampon can i ask you have you done it
since we made the movie yes
[Music]
you have to
but here's the thing i actually don't
use tampons anymore i use a nixon so
when i don't have that with me you can
still do what the rest of us do and make
a pad it doesn't work because then it's
on the outside of my body and i can
smell it smells can't hurt you oh you
smell like ham
oh
they're fully asleep okay i'd rather
have that i think me too a backseat
driver is the sort of thing where i
think i would go through like you know
how when you go through like the whole
life cycle of your emotions and first
you start out sort of feeling like oh i
think they're right and i'm kind of
embarrassed but by the end you're very
very you're ready to be free and you're
willing to say or do anything and to
hurt them by the end of that
you fall in love yeah that's how it
worked for me
and now me and borb are in love
thank you so much buzzfeed we have been
on a journey go see stop and go in
theaters now
[Music]
you